a permuta escambo troca esses eram os
métodos usados na origem nas transações
comerciais inclusive na nossa história
na história brasileira - relatos e
existiam das relações dos portugueses
com os índios
narrado relações de troca bússolas
trocadas por ao brasil
espelho por ouro e prata
essas relações hoje a gente pode
questionar realmente o é o valor mas
isso na época existe uma escassez de um
lado e uma um excesso de produção do do
outro fazia sentido essas trocas e elas
sempre existiram
chega um momento na nossa história de
transações comerciais onde se necessita
de uma moeda para gerenciar essas trocas
eram feitas em vários itens foram
durante a história foram colocados com
moedas apenas conchas na história
brasileira o tabaco foi usado como moeda
o açúcar foi usado como moeda na
história americana oceano durante a
guerra civil americana era usado como
moeda na história mais recente à
alemanha após a primeira guerra ou
porcelana com moedas a moeda foi
necessário para regular essas transações
mas nenhuma moeda foi tão eficiente
quanto o ouro ea prata que devido à sua
facilidade de transporte e cunhagem foi
eleita é a principal moeda de troca
largamente aceita nas transações
comerciais mas ainda com o ouro ea prata
se essas transações ainda não estavam
completas
nós precisávamos de uma instituição que
gerenciasse esse ouro e essa prata que
era a nova moeda
e aí temos o surgimento dos bancos os
bancos então no primeiro momento eles
tinham a única e exclusiva função de um
grande cofre onde a linense guardava o
ouro ea prata
o banco a fonte de receita do banco era
simplesmente um aluguel
o serviço que prestava de guardar o ouro
ea prata em contrapartida eles davam um
certificado pro o depositante é lithium
astro de ouro e prata e certificado lhe
garantia aquela posse o que aconteceu
com esse movimento é que esse
certificado passou a ser comercializado
na cidade passou a ser usado devido à
sua facilidade transporte um papel como
moeda e que se evoluiu ao longo do tempo
e que se tornou o que a gente conhece
hoje como um papel moeda as células
então dinheiro que circula hoje nada
mais é do que um certificado que se
tinha de um astro que você era um
depositário de ouro e prata no banco
esse mecanismo foi tão eficiente nas
transações comerciais em poderão os
bancos de uma tal maneira que os bancos
não só agora mas nos últimos tempos
exerce um poder avassalador no meio
produtivo
hoje em qualquer país não só no brasil a
gente nota o setor produtivo de joelhos
o setor financeiro
quem manda no mundo são os bancos
independente de poder político não
interessa muito quem está ocupando a
casa branca se é um democrata se é um
republicano ou se à presidência do
brasil está com pt ou com o psdb
da forma que está estruturada o toda a
economia todo o sistema financeiro
mundial os bancos mandam todos os o
sistema produtivo
algumas iniciativas com algumas startups
principalmente americanas começam
colocar algumas luzes no fim do túnel na
desconstrução esse sistema que se em
poder um tanto como o sistema financeiro
a startup americana hebe que foca na
parte de hospedagem e que tem atualmente
um valuation
entre 10 e 15 bilhões de dólares
começou em poder a cada um de nós como
fornecedores de hospedagem e
consumidores de hospedagem questionando
o status quo de uma relação onde você
tem os hotéis grandes hotéis fornecendo
hospedagem e todos nós consumindo
hospedagem no novo modelo do eb amb
ele coloca cada um de nós oferecendo uma
cama um quarto uma casa inteira se você
não estiver se estiver viajando em uma
plataforma colaborativa onde você é um
fornecedor e ao mesmo tempo é um
consumidor você pode sim pra outra
cidade e também usado mesmo serviço
isso começa a colocar em xeque a
centralização a oferta existe outro
heyse também muito interessante agora na
área de aluguel de carros comum na
europa e começando a ganhar tração nos
estados unidos que a partir de car
sharing ou compartilhamento de carros e
na mesma forma coloca cada um de nós
como fornecedor de carro e consumidor de
carro então um morador de denver nos
estados unidos pode se dirigir ao
aeroporto
estacionar o seu carro no aeroporto e
pegar o seu vôo para san francisco
enquanto isso o novo passageiro vindo de
nova york usa o carro do morador de rua
enquanto ele está fora e que por sua vez
está em são francisco sá no carro de
outra pessoa que está viajando
veja como essa situação de fundy de
centraliza e deixa um consumo muito mais
responsável consumo muito mais
inteligente e racional os recursos que
temos basicamente ainda se demanda uma
legislação uma regulamentação a respeito
dessas dessas formas de de transações
muitas pessoas já me disseram que seria
impossível
temos uma situação dessa aqui no brasil
por questões de segurança o confiança
o própria legislação mesmo lei mas na
verdade esse não é o ponto aqui hoje
o ponto que eu queria despertar em vocês
é a oportunidade
a tentativa de duas duas estratégias que
estão dando certo não é projeto estão
dando certo e descentralizar o
fornecimento os produtos e serviços
isso muda tudo isso muda tudo porque em
poder a cada um de nós e descentralizar
o fornecimento de bens e serviços
é bem verdade que as transações feitas
nesses dois exemplos que eu citei do
derby ing do cachorro
eles ainda são feitos em dinheiro porque
porque ainda são apenas segmento
isolados onde hospedagem outro de
aluguel de carro
a nossa proposta é criar uma plataforma
colaborativa ampla multissetorial onde
todos os segmentos possam oferecer os
seus produtos e serviços e consumirem
produtos e serviços de outras empresas
na nossa plataforma
o que acontece é que cada um adquiro que
precisa usando que tem sem depender de
um poder centralizado de um banco sem
depender de empréstimo
a plataforma financia todo mundo e todo
mundo paga o seu produto e serviço é
inadmissível ver no jornal da globo há
dois dias atrás
dados da confederação nacional do
comércio dizendo que 63,2 por cento da
população brasileira está endividada e
40% desse público não tem interesse e
não tem na verdade o interesse não tem
condição de quitar a dívida em 2015
não é possível a gente vê esses feirões
de conciliação e arbitragem cada vez
maiores reunindo empresários
profissionais liberais pessoas físicas
endividadas subjugando e se ajoelhando
perante os grandes credores que são os
bancos para negociar uma coisa para
tirar um cpf ou cnpj né a limpar o cnps
cpf ou cnpj
a nossa proposta é de empoderar cada um
de nós
o executor tanto o produtor de produto
ou serviço e cada empresário tem o poder
de decidir o seu consumo e o seu e o seu
conhecimento na verdade não não à
proposta não é anti capitalista ao
contrário nossa proposta é de
intensificar cada vez mais o consumo eo
fornecimento mas intensificar
potencializando a na verdade o poder de
quem produz o produto e serviço
queremos potencializar o empresário o
empreendedor
o autônomo o prestador de serviço
esse sim que presta o serviço precisa de
empoderamento está numa rede
compartilhada para poder adequar seu
consumo com as suas demandas e não os
bancos
na verdade não produzem nada e mandou no
sistema nem um sistema comercial essa é
a nossa proposta é essa é o que a gente
acredita que o futuro o futuro
colaborativo
eu acredito nisso muito obrigado a todos